SPEAKER_00: Thanks for coming in, uh, how's retirement treating you so far? I know it's been... what, six months now?
SPEAKER_01: Well, that's actually why I'm here. I'm getting... I'm getting really nervous about my numbers.
SPEAKER_00: Okay, let's dive into it. You retired at sixty-two, right? About... um... six months ago? Let me check my notes here...
SPEAKER_01: Yeah, I couldn't take the stress at work anymore. But now I'm stressed about money instead.
SPEAKER_00: Understandable. So you've got, what, about... let me see... eight hundred thousand in your 401k and IRA combined? Is that still current?
SPEAKER_01: Eight twenty-five as of last month. Market's been volatile.
SPEAKER_00: Right, and you're not taking Social Security yet. That's actually smart - your benefit grows... um... eight percent each year until seventy. Or is it seven point five? I should double-check that.
SPEAKER_01: But I need income now. I've been living off savings and it's... it's draining fast.
SPEAKER_00: How much are you spending monthly? We need to figure out your, um, burn rate. Do you have those numbers handy?
SPEAKER_01: About forty-five hundred a month. House is paid off, but taxes, utilities, food... it all adds up, you know?
SPEAKER_00: So fifty-four thousand annually. That's actually pretty reasonable for your lifestyle. Some clients spend way more than-- than that.
SPEAKER_01: Really? It feels like a lot when I'm not earning anything. Every purchase makes me... makes me anxious.
SPEAKER_00: Well, the four percent rule suggests you could safely withdraw about, let me see... thirty-three thousand from your portfolio. Actually, wait, that's based on eight twenty-five, so... um, let me recalculate that.
SPEAKER_01: That's only twenty-seven fifty a month. I need more than-- way more than that.
SPEAKER_00: Right, which is why we need to bridge you to Social Security. What will your benefit be at full retirement age? Did you bring that statement?
SPEAKER_01: Um, the estimate says about twenty-eight hundred a month. At least I think that's what it said.
SPEAKER_00: And that's at sixty-seven. If you wait until seventy, it would be around... um... thirty-six hundred. That's a rough estimate though.
SPEAKER_01: Eight hundred more per month just for waiting three years?
SPEAKER_00: Exactly. That's an extra nine thousand six hundred annually, guaranteed for life. Hard to beat that return.
SPEAKER_01: But I need money now, not in eight years. I can't wait that long.
SPEAKER_00: I understand. So let's create a bridge strategy. Maybe a more aggressive withdrawal rate early on, though that's... that's riskier.
SPEAKER_01: More aggressive? I don't-- I mean, how risky are we talking here? I'm already losing sleep over this.
SPEAKER_01: How aggressive are we talking?
SPEAKER_00: Well, you could withdraw five percent now, then dial it back when Social Security kicks in. Though, um, let me double-check those withdrawal rates... I think five percent is still considered safe-ish for short periods.
SPEAKER_01: Five percent of eight twenty-five... that's about forty-one thousand. Still short of what I need.
SPEAKER_00: Right, plus you probably have some other assets. Don't you own some rental properties? Or did you sell those already?
SPEAKER_01: Just one now. Sold the other two last year. Net about six hundred a month after... after all the expenses.
SPEAKER_00: Okay, so that's seven thousand two hundred annually. So we need about... let's see... six thousand eight hundred more. Wait, is my math right there? Let me double-check...
SPEAKER_01: That doesn't seem too bad when you put it that way. Though I'm still-- still worried.
SPEAKER_00: It's not. But we need to be strategic about which accounts we tap first. Have you heard of the bucket strategy? It's... it's pretty popular these days.
SPEAKER_01: No, what's that?
SPEAKER_00: Think of your money in three buckets. Short-term cash, medium-term bonds, long-term stocks. It's a... it's a pretty common strategy these days.
SPEAKER_01: So I don't have to sell stocks when the market's down? That's-- that's the idea?
SPEAKER_00: Exactly. You've got five years of expenses in cash and bonds, stocks have time to recover from downturns. At least that's... that's the theory anyway.
SPEAKER_01: Makes sense. What's my allocation now? I haven't really been paying attention.
SPEAKER_00: Looking at your statements, you're about... um... sixty-forty stocks to bonds. Pretty standard for your age. Though maybe we should-- actually, let me look at this closer.
SPEAKER_01: Is that too aggressive for retirement? I mean, should I be more--
SPEAKER_00: Actually, with your timeline, maybe not aggressive enough. You could live another thirty years. Or more, who knows with medical advances these days.
SPEAKER_01: Thirty years? God, I hope I don't run out of money.
SPEAKER_00: That's why we need growth. Inflation alone will cut your purchasing power in half over twenty years.
SPEAKER_01: Even at two percent inflation?
SPEAKER_00: Well, core CPI is running over three percent now. And healthcare inflation is historically much higher.
SPEAKER_01: Don't remind me. My insurance premiums just went up fifteen percent.
SPEAKER_00: Exactly. That's why I'm thinking maybe seventy-thirty stocks to bonds for the long-term bucket.
SPEAKER_01: And the short-term money?
SPEAKER_00: High-yield savings, maybe some CDs. You can get over four percent risk-free right now.
SPEAKER_01: That's better than my bonds are doing.
SPEAKER_00: Bond funds have been rough with rates rising. But they'll do better when rates eventually fall.
SPEAKER_01: When do you think that'll happen?
SPEAKER_00: Your guess is as good as mine. Fed funds is at five and a quarter. Could stay there a while if inflation persists. I honestly-- I honestly don't know. Nobody does.
SPEAKER_01: This interest rate stuff is confusing.
SPEAKER_00: Think of it this way - higher rates are actually good for retirees with cash. Bad for bond prices, though.
SPEAKER_01: So should I sell my bond funds?
SPEAKER_00: Not necessarily. Maybe shift some to shorter duration bonds. They're less sensitive to rate changes.
SPEAKER_01: What about I Bonds? I keep hearing about those.
SPEAKER_00: Treasury Inflation-Protected Securities? They're great, but you can only buy ten thousand per year. Or is it... wait, let me check if that limit changed recently.
SPEAKER_01: Still, ten thousand is ten thousand.
SPEAKER_00: True. They're paying about five percent now, and they adjust for inflation. Can't beat that.
SPEAKER_01: I should have bought them years ago.
SPEAKER_00: Nobody saw this inflation coming. Even the Fed called it transitory, remember? That was... that was completely wrong. Shows you how hard this stuff is to predict.
SPEAKER_01: Yeah, that didn't age well.
SPEAKER_00: Point is, we can't predict everything. That's why diversification is so important.
SPEAKER_01: Speaking of which, what about international stocks?
SPEAKER_00: You've got very little international exposure. Maybe fifteen percent of your stock allocation should be overseas.
SPEAKER_01: Haven't they been underperforming the US for years?
SPEAKER_00: They have, but valuations are much cheaper now. European stocks are trading at thirteen times earnings.
SPEAKER_01: Versus what for US stocks?
SPEAKER_00: S&P 500 is at about twenty-four times. Emerging markets are even cheaper at twelve times.
SPEAKER_01: So they're due for a comeback?
SPEAKER_00: Maybe. Currencies could be a headwind, but from a valuation standpoint, they look attractive.
SPEAKER_01: I'm not a big risk-taker at this point.
SPEAKER_00: Understood. But not diversifying is also a risk. What if the US has a decade like Japan in the nineties?
SPEAKER_01: Their stock market went nowhere for ten years, right?
SPEAKER_00: Longer than that, actually. The Nikkei peaked in nineteen eighty-nine and didn't recover until twenty eighteen.
SPEAKER_01: Jesus. Okay, some international exposure makes sense.
SPEAKER_00: Good. Now, let's talk about tax-efficient withdrawals. You've got both traditional and Roth accounts, right?
SPEAKER_01: Yeah, about two-thirds traditional, one-third Roth.
SPEAKER_00: Perfect. In low-income years like now, you want to withdraw from traditional accounts first.
SPEAKER_01: To fill up the lower tax brackets?
SPEAKER_00: Exactly. The twelve percent bracket goes up to about twenty-two thousand for a single person.
SPEAKER_01: So I should withdraw at least that much from my 401k?
SPEAKER_00: Probably more. Remember, you'll have standard deduction of thirteen thousand eight fifty, so no tax on that.
SPEAKER_01: So I could withdraw thirty-five thousand and only pay twelve percent?
SPEAKER_00: On the taxable portion, yes. That's way less than you'll pay when RMDs kick in at seventy-three.
SPEAKER_01: RMDs? Required minimum distributions?
SPEAKER_00: Right. The IRS forces you to withdraw a percentage each year. Starts at about four percent.
SPEAKER_01: So I'll have to pay taxes whether I want to or not.
SPEAKER_00: Exactly. That's why it makes sense to do some Roth conversions now while you're in a low bracket.
SPEAKER_01: Convert traditional IRA money to Roth?
SPEAKER_00: Yes. Pay taxes now at twelve percent instead of potentially twenty-two or twenty-four percent later.
SPEAKER_01: But that means more taxes now when money's already tight.
SPEAKER_00: I know it's counterintuitive. But it's like prepaying at a discount. Plus, Roth money doesn't have RMDs.
SPEAKER_01: And I can leave it to my kids tax-free?
SPEAKER_00: Well, they'll have to withdraw it over ten years now, but yeah, no taxes on the withdrawals.
SPEAKER_01: That's still better than leaving them a tax bill.
SPEAKER_00: Absolutely. Especially if they're in high-earning years. Could save them a fortune.
SPEAKER_01: Okay, I'm sold on some conversions.
SPEAKER_00: Great. Maybe we do twenty thousand a year for the next few years. Stay in that twelve percent bracket.
SPEAKER_01: And I'd pay about twenty-four hundred in taxes?
SPEAKER_00: Something like that. Small price to pay for future tax flexibility.
SPEAKER_01: This is a lot to think about.
SPEAKER_00: I know. But having a plan reduces the stress. You're not just winging it anymore.
SPEAKER_01: True. What about healthcare costs?
SPEAKER_00: Big concern. Fidelity estimates a sixty-five-year-old couple needs three hundred thousand for medical expenses in retirement.
SPEAKER_01: Three hundred thousand? That's terrifying.
SPEAKER_00: It includes insurance premiums, not just out-of-pocket costs. But yeah, it's substantial.
SPEAKER_01: Thank god I've got decent coverage now.
SPEAKER_00: What are you paying? And remember, Medicare doesn't start until sixty-five.
SPEAKER_01: I'm on COBRA for now. About eight hundred a month.
SPEAKER_00: That's actually not bad. Marketplace plans for someone your age can be twelve hundred or more.
SPEAKER_01: I've got two more years of COBRA eligibility.
SPEAKER_00: Good, that bridges you to Medicare. Though you might want to look at ACA plans to compare.
SPEAKER_01: Depending on income, I might qualify for subsidies?
SPEAKER_00: Exactly. If your modified AGI is under fifty-one thousand, you'd get premium assistance.
SPEAKER_01: Another reason to manage my withdrawal strategy carefully.
SPEAKER_00: Right. Too much income and you lose subsidies. Too little and you're not optimizing your tax situation.
SPEAKER_01: It's like walking a tightrope.
SPEAKER_00: A bit, yeah. But that's where good planning pays off. Small moves can save thousands.
SPEAKER_01: What about long-term care insurance?
SPEAKER_00: Good question. The average stay is about three years at around ninety thousand annually. Actually, let me... let me verify those numbers. They might be outdated.
SPEAKER_01: So two hundred seventy thousand total?
SPEAKER_00: For nursing home care, yeah. Home care is less expensive but still substantial.
SPEAKER_01: Is insurance worth it at my age?
SPEAKER_00: Premiums are expensive, and they can increase over time. But it protects your other assets.
SPEAKER_01: What would something basic cost?
SPEAKER_00: For a sixty-two-year-old male, maybe three to four thousand annually for decent coverage. Though, uh, those numbers might have changed with recent rate increases.
SPEAKER_01: That's a significant chunk of my budget.
SPEAKER_00: It is. Alternative is to self-insure - keep extra cash for potential care needs.
SPEAKER_01: I think I'd rather stay flexible.
SPEAKER_00: Fair enough. Just factor it into your planning. Maybe keep an extra hundred thousand in conservative investments.
SPEAKER_01: That makes sense. Oh, before I forget-- my daughter's been asking about my finances lately too.
SPEAKER_00: Oh? Well, it's good she's concerned-- um, alright, let me summarize what we've discussed. Bridge strategy until Social Security, bucket approach for withdrawals...
SPEAKER_01: Some international diversification, Roth conversions...
SPEAKER_00: Right, and careful attention to tax brackets and healthcare subsidy thresholds.
SPEAKER_01: When should we implement all this?
SPEAKER_00: We can start gradually. Maybe begin with moving some money to higher-yield cash accounts. No need to rush into everything at once.
SPEAKER_01: And then tackle the portfolio rebalancing?
SPEAKER_00: Exactly. No need to do everything at once. Rome wasn't built in a day, as they say.
SPEAKER_01: I feel much better having a roadmap.
SPEAKER_00: Good. Retirement shouldn't be about constant worry. You've done well saving for this phase of your life.
SPEAKER_01: I just wish I'd started planning sooner.
SPEAKER_00: Second-best time to plant a tree is today, right? We'll get you set up for a comfortable retirement. I'm confident we can make this work.
SPEAKER_01: Thanks. This has been really helpful.
SPEAKER_00: My pleasure. Let's schedule a follow-up in, um, about a month to see how the plan is working out for you.
SPEAKER_01: Perfect. I'll bring my latest statements.
SPEAKER_00: Sounds good. Try to enjoy your retirement - you've definitely earned it.